TO A PARADE SO THEY ARE HOPING
HE CAN BE THE MAIN MAN AS THE
PLAYOFFS COME AROUND AND WE GET
THIS GAME UNDERWAY.
>> BROUGHT TO YO SIDE OF
ON B
REBOUND.
DACH TRIED TO SCORE FROM BEHIND
HOCKEY DOES NOT GET ANY BETTER.
HAGEL FINDS KIRBY.    O HIGH
FOR PARAYKO CAN REALLY DRIFT.
HERE IS TARASENKO.
DROPPING INTO BIG SAVE.
HERE IS THE DRIVE.
OFF DEBRINCAT
THEY GO BACK DOOR.
TO KYROU.
GREAT PASSING PLAY BY THE
BLUES.
THAT IS NE.
EVERYBODY IS GOING ONE
DIRECTION.
THEN THE
LOOKING FOR SCHENN. OUT WITH KA.
AND THEN GOING RIGHT TO LEFT.
JUST A SIGN THAT IT MIGHT STOP.
RETHE NET.
2-0,
REBOUND.
GOOD SAVED THEIR WITH A  INITIA
OPPORTUNITY.BLUES HAVE.
LO
IN FRONT.
PICKED OFF.
THERE COMES KANE.
TO THE NET. TS.
BLUES BOOTED FROM SIDE TO SIDE.
SECOND OR THIRD GOAL THAT WAY.
WHEN YOUR SCRAMBLING ANDND THE .
PERRON FROM THE GOAL LINE T BAR
LINE.
WE
POWERPLAY.
>> PAT: NEV
THE UNITED CENTER.
TO THE NET.
SAVED BY BINNINGTON.
NOT OVJORDAN
BINNINGTON.
AND THENST.
LOUIS.  THEN YOU HAVE TO GO BAC
OTHER SIDE.
IT IS VERY METHODICAL AND .
KYRO
MURPHY.
BOZAK ONCE PERRON.
THE SHOT.
FLEURY, WHAT A STOP!